est ce que selon l'avis que je sens je
sois des mauvaises vibrations la gestion
question bon il ya des miennes il ya des
gens mal intentionnés win qui m'ont dit
vous allez rencontrer qui est ce samedi
soir il est il est très gentil mais il
vous surnomme j'ai plutôt ce qui est
gentil mais aussi au djembé et on m'a
dit vous savez que nous en france inter
on le surnomme aux pics je dis pourquoi
et on va dire ce qu'il arrive le matin à
7h et pour avoir pour avoir les droits
de la sacem c'est ça il écrit il écrit
ses textes et il se situe chaque fois
oui comme ça il touche 15 francs et
celle annoncée en blanc n'y a pas non
non non abbas et non il demander si on
peut répondre 'sinon il sait bien
pourquoi m pour toi je vais vous
l'expliquer mais je peux répondre avant
votre attaque non il a bon sourire bah
oui pourquoi mais dh expliqué gilbert je
vous aime beaucoup
je vous remercie 2 est-ce que ça qu'est
ce que c'est
j'ai l'impression que sur les 2 celui
qui manque d'humour ce n'est pas moins
bon ben c'est moi j'ai pas qu'on peut on
veut sortir de ça
non on en survie deux choses donc j'ai
pas d'humour moi j'ai pas du cinoche
rigorisme être gepetto hommes alors mais
tant mieux tant mieux tant mieux c'est
bien c'est bien de faire rire en
humoriste s'il est pas capable de rire
de lui parce que je veux vous dire
simplement c'est que moi j'ai beaucoup
de sympathie pour je trouve je trouve
que quand vous m'avez appelé m geppetto
ça m'a fait rire c'est toujours pas j'ai
fait moi j'aurais fait mentir virac
voilà c'est le débat alors là on est
triste pour moi je ne sais pas si c'est
vous qui aviez vous remercie en
communication et non la la je veux pas
ce que c'est les bruins avaient laissé
leur réponds non tout d'abord je pose la
question est est ce que c'est vous qui
avez dit est ce que c'est vous qui avez
dit rire hein dis que tu t'es jamais
dopé n'en attendez vous on est où là
allez-vous à la télévision ça n'en veut
dire son délire inquiétante celle là
parce que avec vision et la vérité j'ai
hébergé vous voulez dire la vérité moi
sur l'affairé pas inquiétant sur la
faire virer
j'ai assuré la défense de richard viré
ouais deux mâles brochard bien bien ils
courent aujourd'hui il n'est pas
sanctionné camarades ouais bon alors il
entre aussi court
ils ont été sanctionnés oui mais ils ont
été sanctionnés lui a été sanctionné par
les médias effectivement là les médias
rachat voilà la religion des médias on
va passer le débat aussi on va en parler
parce qu'il ya deux aspects dans la
sphère on va en parler et c'est pas faux
c'est pas négligeable
je défends donc richard virait je
défends moreau je défend pascal hervé
moreau va avoué pascal hervé vanier
richard virenque vanillé c'était en
garde à vue vous n'avez jamais été en
garde à vue n'ont sûrement sur d'accord
d'accord pour pendant la garde à vue
vous savez que l'avocat brian déclassait
d'un cran me défendre
alors là bon quand il bégaie passé pas
mal bon bon alors alors vous avez quand
tu vois les gens qui ne gagnent rien
parce que j'ai beaucoup beaucoup mais
bon pendant la garde à vue pendant la
garde à vue j'étais palabres et richard
virenque a été gardé en vie
trente heures je crois j'étais pas là
bon et ce qu'il a dit aux policiers ce
que pascal hervé a dit aux policiers ce
que brochard a dit aux policiers ce que
moraux que je défends des hausses il a
dit aux policiers
je n'ai pas soufflé dire que c'est
injuste c'est injuste franchement et
pour être très très sincère c'est vrai
que je le prends un peu mal oui mais
voilà par exemple j'ai un avocat
bon des fois je me trouve oui je me
trompe je dis oui voila moi je vais
aller attaquer ma maison 10 parce qu'il
fait chaud
oui et tout est ce que je vais dire ok
ça n'engage que moi mais elle elle est
là pour brawn essayait me dire ça ça
mais vous serez là dedans je continue à
partir du moment où on lui il a fait une
chose quelque chose qui est pas bien
c'est à dire ne pas dire la vérité parce
qu'apparemment moi j'en sais mais
apparemment ça par amour
donc vous savez dopé mais moi ce que je
trouve un nom tout le monde se fout
mention et clément vous sortez famars un
mensuel qui s'appelle m dimanche
vous avez dans vous avez dans quinze
jours un livre sur vire un qui sort vous
vous connaissez un cyclisme le débat
vous l'avez entendu c'est à dire que et
surtout après avoir lu le livre
formidable mais oui mais ça je trouve
étonnant c'est la fièvre qui lie à
autour du simple monde richard virenque
cercle si le cyclisme est un sport
populaire avant dans les salons
parisiens tout le monde se foutait
éperdument du tour j'ai fait cinq tours
de france comme journaliste et les
copains me traitait entre guillemets
deux blaireaux avec la célèbre casquette
a priori quelques onces caricature
estampillé marque dany et ses draps et
d'un seul coup on ne peut plus faire un
salon parisien sans que le nom de
richard virenque soient cités et des
gens qui le mot l'est d'ailleurs sans
grandes preuves et qui n'ont pas dû lire
tout le dossier font parfois c'est vrai
un humour un peu acide venez vous
expliquez moi je vous dirais que j'ai
rien contre lui mais je trouve
alors je te dirais que choisir une
soirée sans parler de virac d'offrir une
chose clairement en ce qui concerne
richard dans le dossier moi je peux en
parler j'ai été en garde à vue a eu
accès au dossier
les analyses de richard jusqu'ici sont
négativement la alors quoi qu'il ait
fait moi je ne suis pas les hommages de
richard qui est un pote de quel droit tu
ne peux pas dire aujourd'hui il s'est
dopé même 656 doc si je me suis pas dopé
que ces analyses sont négatives - la
droite mourir sur scène c'est comme
roland dumas c'est la présomption
d'innocence mais c'est pas que ça je
crois avant tout à l'heure il ay là j'ai
voulu faire une démonstration peut-être
maladroite jument extrême
je reconnais bon bon mais ça démontre au
moins une chose c'est alors que j'ai vu
la voir mais est ce que c'est que on
peut balancer n'importe quelle
accusation bon ce qu'il dit est vrai le
dossier ne démontre pas que richard
virale se serait dopé mois richard me
rinck le le colloque entre lui et moi
vous n'y étiez pas vous ne savez pas ce
conseiller
il a bon c'est clair il a toujours
affirmé et encore maintenant
même quand je n'y suis pas je ne me suis
pas dopé moi en tant qu'avocat vont
devoir après qu'on ait un entretien que
vous ne connaissez pas c'est de coller à
ce qui dit je veux dire je n'ai qu'à
attendait ça c'est important c'est le
premier truc intelligible depuis le
début cela c'est ce que vous dites vous
sais pas si c'est pas beau qui lui avait
conseillé de nier s'être dopé c'est lui
qui a commencé par dire je me suis pas
dopé et vous êtes aligné sur sa position
bien sûr je comprends je vous écris que
je vous expliquer pourquoi parce que
s'il avait eu des éléments objectifs du
dossier permettant de démontrer qu'il
s'était dopé
ouais je lui aurais dit mais j'adore tu
vas dire qu'il fait jour en pleine nuit
bon mais tout ce qu'il dit est
corroborée dans le dossier une tous qui
dit est confirmée c'est jamais dû
attraper bon je vous en prie nous sommes
vraiment à meaux essayons essayons pas
ce que ça peu tous un jour
on est bien pendant trois mois ça allait
arriver moi j'ai le corps en mer des
beaux espoirs de voir nommer notre
histoire même personne est à l'abri
d'une rumeur de bien sûr une à plusieurs
sociétés dénoncé déplacer bon bon bon
il n'y a pas de preuve bon la justice de
bureaux d'un accord il ya un bon
pourquoi l'attaqué et attaquer son âme
mais d'accord voilà d'accord avec une
avec une chose à une différence près
c'est que les humoristes ne font pas un
travail d'un vêtement mais je défends ma
paroisse ils sont pas et je défends les
guignols gore qui font ça tous les soirs
ils font pas un travail d'investigation
les humoristes issus attaquez vous aux
journalistes plutôt qu aux humoristes
parce que non mais laissez moi terminer
c'est parce que les humoristes et c'est
pas eux qui disent que virenque à une
mauvaise stratégie
c'est pas toi qui disent ah oui il
récupère ce qu'ils lisent dans les
journaux grâce à en faire de l'humour on
sait pourquoi vous attaquez à nous
plutôt quand on demande à quoi vous
attendre et et vous alors
grâce à cet échange attendez attendez
non mais c'est même pas une question moi
je moi je trouve que s'attaquer à un
seul type je trouve ça toujours
dégueulasse il faut s'attaquer au
système est assis ça profite réellement
je veux plus faire je pense que voilà je
pense que la doc dans le sport il y en a
ras dans tous les trucs dans tous les
coins dans machin mais je trouve que la
france bien j'ai un petit pour bell me
planquer
non mais je trouve que c'est dégueulasse
à s'attaquer à un seul mec quoi et de
l'abîmé comme ça il est surtout très
abîmée richard pour cette campagne de
moins et quand même il se démerde bien
dans le paris nice lens et vous qu'avez
conclure parce que c'est fini le mois de
décembre fut un paquet font rire
venez-vous est vraiment il y a laissé
des plumes dans ce qui est souverain sa
chair parce que ce que je disais tout à
l'heure il fait partie d'un milieu bon
vous faire revivre catholiques
dissidents vote blocage de la sorte et à
cri le livre non pas sur richard mais
avec richard virenque aulas avec guy
qu'a pu nous sommes les collaborateurs
pour aider richard à faire son livre
alors réservé un livre ses moyens
l'homme est riche allons nous dans une
vraie 6 et culte où les journalistes
n'ont pas lapidée richard et range peux
vous dire qu'il a raison pas c'est moi
qui écrit le livre de richard virenque
pour toucher les droits vous remercie